bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors déjà quelque chose
qui interroge et derniers chiffres
disponibles date de 2015 pourquoi balle
tout simplement parce que les le temps
de faire les recensements et de pouvoir
avoir des chiffres importants tels que
cela met met du temps on ne travaille
toujours en retard avec un peu tous les
chiffres de l'insee malheureusement je
travaillais moins sur les installations
chez jeunes agriculteurs et les chiffres
des installations on les a quasiment un
an voire un an et demi après car les
données statistiques sont vraiment
complexe à à remonter alors est ce que
ce rapport remis aujourd'hui prouve que
la question du mal être des agriculteurs
on n'est plus un tabou
effectivement je pense avec les nombreux
sujets sur le site agricole
je pense qu'au dernier film au nom de la
terre le sujet du suicide agricole est
de moins en moins tabou il reste encore
un tabou dans certaines dans certaines
certains départements dans certaines
exploitations mais je pense que la
parole se libère et on a de plus en plus
de facilité à discuter du suite il en
agriculture
est ce que ce rapport plusieurs petits
dans son rapport est ce que il vous
satisfait alors il y a des propositions
qui nous satisfont effectivement dans ce
rapport il est il parle qu'il faut
soutenir plus les agriculteurs les
agriculteurs qui sont comme vous l'avez
précisé en pleine crise encore énième
année de suite je pense que nous avons
besoin d'être d'être valorisé d'être
valorisés par
les consommateurs je pense que c'est
important que les consommateurs puissent
nous prouver leur attachement à leurs
agriculteurs français ce qui est
important c'est qu'on nous valorise
plutôt que de nous opposer valoriser les
hommes les femmes plutôt que d'essayer
de nous diviser
classé en différents dans différentes
cases ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
agriculteurs travaillent tous les jours
pour nous nourrir nous mangeons trois
repas par jour les agriculteurs
travaillent tous les jours toute l'année
pour justement donné à tous les
consommateurs
cette nourriture de qualité et nous nous
trouvons parfois que nous ne sommes pas
assez valorisé alors que nous produisons
l'agriculture la prude durable et il
faut continuer cette valorisation qui
est dense
dans ce rapport clairement dit donc
effectivement il ya des choses qui nous
qui nous vont plutôt très bien dans ce
rapport justement plusieurs pistes 1
dans ce rapport dont la création de 100
tinner ce sera à qui ses sont in hell et
comment elles vont s'organiser alors sur
tous les départements
il ya déjà des cellules un peu mise en
place je pense aux services de la msa
qui rompt des services spéciaux
d'experts de personnes qui sont là pour
pour écouter les agriculteurs qui sont
en difficulté mais il y a besoin d'avoir
quelque chose d'uniformes et de partager
les bonnes pratiques sur tous les
territoires et de mettre ça en place
alors qu'ils seront les sentinelles je
peux pas voulu répondre c'est à sa
demande un peu de un peu de travail mais
mais je pense que il faut miser sur les
bonnes pratiques qu'on peut observer sur
les territoires et essayer de les
mutualiser et de les partager sur tout
le territoire
françois etienne merci et merci à vous
je répète vous êtes vice président du
syndicat des jeunes agriculteurs merci